hey guys merry here with a gamespot news  update the NPD numbers are in and  although Sony's PlayStation did manage  to outsell the Xbox one for the month of  June Microsoft's did pull off a little  victory Xbox executive aaron greenberg  writes on twitter the xbox one actually  outsold the ps4 during the week of e3  2015 xbox one sales rose of whopping  seventy-nine percent compared to the  week of e3 2014 greenberg pointed out  that Batman Arkham Knight ps4 console  bundles sold extremely well and helped  ps4 get the overall edge it was also  revealed that the Xbox one backwards  compatibility program is going very well  with more than 30 million minutes of  xbox 360 games played on xbox one since  June fifteenth hardware sales overall  were up eight percent year-over-year  with 313 point 1 million compared to  last year's 290 1.1 million not  surprisingly Batman Arkham Knight was  the top-selling game of the month for  the latest news be sure to head to  gamespot com